komm komm ich rette dich hätte ich bin
auf dem weg die sind ja überall die sind
ja überall hier sind jetzt welche von
den töten bitte ja ich gucke ja quasi
nur an und dann verschwinden die die
haben ja angst vor mir hallo ich meine
lieben villiger paradies und herzlich
willkommen zu einer weiteren folge
captain minecraft drei zusammen mit goma
hd-programme wahrlich wann du du hast du
ein paar blähungen heute habe ich ja als
gefühle leute direkt vor der aufnahme
auf einmal erschreckt mich total auf
einmal kommt so ein fisch vor mich
untersteht mining verteilt vier minuten
20 und wenn ich abbaue
doch die totale nicht mehr so lang wir
müssen einfach weiter am gleichen block
immer gleichzeitig abbauen damit wir
erschaffen komisch was ich will schon
wieder der wald wir verlängert auf 74
das ist so wie wenn wir drei minuten 50
euro wie aber soll ich sagen nein also
soll ich sagen warum das nicht macht
weil wir jetzt durch die fertigen tunnel
schwimmen und die fackeln können wir
danach waren weiterhin setzen und
dadurch luft bekommen die mine hat uns
nämlich mal informiert und wir wollten
ihren häufig tunnel schwimmen wir durch
den gleichen turnen schwimmen ja
wirklich doch vorschlag mit ihren
fackeln oder eine fackel
hier wollte was denn hier oben kommt mal
lang und würde mich geschehen dass man
auch mit normalen fackeln ganz normal
kurz luft holen kann ich jetzt mal meine
erste sorge ich habe sicher vor luft
aber man sieht dadurch halt auch relativ
wenig ich bin noch wurde klar ich will
es einmal helga schwimmer hier hoch bis
zu unter mir okay findet ihr hier wollen
wir nicht mal wieder der luft ein
bisschen so ich habe wiederholt
schwimmen weil hier meine hoch als sieht
aber echt gut aus sie waren wir doch gar
nicht verbinden
das war irgendwie so ein wasserloch das
ist irgendwie kokett ist bisschen doof
war nämlich nix mehr eine truhe mit ruhe
wo siehst du nicht ruhe hier unten
ich komme gar nix da bleibt man da
stehen runter und ja jetzt nicht ein
^ ^ ^ okay siehst du mich nicht doch
jetzt sehe ich dich und es sind ruhe
ich würde so gern den block bauen und
die fackel hatte ich kann ihn sogar ich
kann mir sogar eine fackel wo der rother
hier drüben da da nach vorne
hallo guck dir mal die truhe weil du
hast auch aufnahme aber nicht damit
sterben mit dem thron inhalt ich sehe ja
nicht mal eine truhe er einfach runter
schwimmen fast warum immer auf
einstellungen gucken ob du deiner
entfernt ist dunkel eingestellt das
heißt auch da unten da sehe ich eine
truhe oder ist porschen auf night vision
aber können wir die ein bisschen
mitgucken press marien kristalle und
gold nugget
das ist gut das hilft uns wartet
blindfische wir müssen wir müssen wir
müssen die filme müssen wir müssen öfter
villiger party zu müssen so wo ich stehe
wir müssen die kiste abbauen die himmels
nikita abgeholt als sicher und man wir
müssen dieses meininger ich habe das
immer noch 21 okay gut dann kommt wieder
fisch wird weil ich glaube aber nicht
hatte von auch noch den effekt und naja
ich brauche auf jeden fall night vision
für jeden acht minuten genau partie
nieder das ist nicht beides night vision
das water briefing dass man unter wasser
atmen kann und night vision soll ich das
einfach mal nehmen weil ich jetzt
aufnehmen und blabla ich weiß nicht aber
mache es dann wenn wir wirklich keine
ablehnung mehr haben dann würde ich das
machen hier habe ich habe auch nichts
mehr zu essen ich habe auch ein bisschen
angst nur noch vier herz wird das gegen
die decke vielleicht bekommen wir beide
den effekt wenn es ist keine vision dass
eine trinkpause
hast du eventuell was zu essen für mich
ist fünf minuten da war wieder der fisch
echtes ich hasse diesen fähig ich es nie
wieder viel schwitzen wir bald mal in
einer anderen tunnel rein finde ich ja
also da ich weiß sehen weiter während
wir gehen jetzt erst mal wieder aber
immer und wir müssen uns den wir hier
markieren mit welche nicht noch tausende
reingezogen oder echt ich sehe hier noch
sonne
hier ist aber nur die world order
meldewege nicht okay hier weiterhin sind
wir falsch wie kam von hier
okay ich bin ich bin mir unter ihrer
jacke hier aufgestellt hier waren wir
schon mal hier mit schlag ich auch noch
so langsam
ich habe echt schiss vor diesem blöden
kann man sich da nicht irgendwie frau
widmen wir brauchen milch irgendwie ja
das wäre echt geil
manchmal richtig gut hier können wir
doch nicht lachen ja ganz steile hast du
dich deine ränge
bald stellt hofmann ich komme hier nicht
im block ab der oma kannst der kreis
da kannst du nicht wieder abbauen doch
nicht ich habe mich ich hätte einen gang
hoch hier kann ich hoch hier war ich
aber schon mal hier kommt glaube ich
gleich die truhe wo ich schon mal dran
bekommen einfach wieder steine war ich
dann meine ich weiß wann ich glaube da
den hoch zeiten wieder den hochkommen
besitzt aber ich hier nochmal kommt
schon alle guten dinge sind vier und
hier wieder stein oder wie anhin in den
e
hier kann hochwertig neue bereiche
kennen lernt das neue an hier sind wie
steine hat mit joghurt mit fisch ich
sehe wie da soll ich bin neben
und wem von vögeln tod von diesem scheiß
von diesem verdammten scheiß fisch ich
hatte diesen fisch enthält mich auch
gerade wie er belässt sich dabei hat
mich nicht getötet monaten werde ich
getötet
du bist der trunkenheit pro nein die
intensität doch im chat stimmt aber ich
hab geträumt guardian ich habe deine
sachen eingesammelt okay das gut ist
erwartet
ich glaube ich glaube davon nicht
angreifen dann hast du ja noch unsere
unsere leiter ein stückchen kaputt mit
denen mit denen mit den jahren
doch warum wächst das ding denn ich war
nicht voll doof
wir sollten jetzt hoch kompressor etwa
wieder den normalen weg so ein bisschen
und noch eine truhe gefunden jetzt tun
ich sehe nur noch creeper überall ich
hab da atmung cell mit drin gefunden
unter anderem und wir ganzen filme sind
richtig wertvoll
ja was ich kann alle sind auch richtig
viele spinnen und andere böse viecher
ich komme aber gerade mal nicht runter
weil ich gerade wirklich das gefühl habe
ich hab mal was versuchen die malerei
toto-lotto ja okay okay das ist richtig
gut es waren nur noch lapislazuli und
dann können wir diesmal gert acker
machen mache kentucky und es geht auch
weiter kräftig harte weg gefunden
hier ist carsten pieper wünscht viel
glück gewünscht
ich habe richtig level und schon diese
truhe hab ich gesagt was wir sofort bei
die ich bin sofort bei dir ich sehe die
einnahmen sogar schon echt ist und ich
habe eine kleine abbau wirklich nicht
sofort bei mir seit ewigkeiten und der
boss wir unter mir und das ding ist ich
bin hier durch tausende gänge nach oben
geschoben und jetzt ist der boss genau
unter mir was sollen das erwartete
kämpft hier wie sie hatte nein wieso
kommt der denn ich habe zwei posten weil
wir nein aber wer wie so leute wie so
kommt denn dieser scheiß fisch ich hab
schon wieder diese fünf minuten
wieso kommt er denn zu mir aber wie
sicher auch die sowieso denn zu mir ob
ich denn getan
ich laufe nur so friedlich rum möchte
ich ein bisschen spaß ich hab nie tötet
mich tötet mich komme du schaffst es
passt es kann auch immer wieder oft
tauchen hier schutzalter shit ich glaube
ich packe alles erst mal eine truhe die
ich hier im park ok macht das verdammt
ich hab diese abbau lähmung und das soll
jetzt einfach ewigkeiten bisschen blog
über mir ich hab ich nämlich zugebaut
jetzt gerade ich darf auf keinen fall
die tour weiter verlieren
ja das hat mir schon mal der dürfe also
ich weiß nicht woher das kommt ich habe
so eine blöde vermutung dass man immer
daran diese chance bekommt denn wenn der
quasi wenn man so ein blog
da ist er ist dieser fisch wo bist du
ich bin weiter oben ich bin einfach mal
nach oben geschoben immer den gang nach
oben folgen
irgendwie das ding ist man kann auch
manchmal nach links und rechts schwimmer
sind ihm viele guardians alter ja wir
waren auch schon eben gerade drei auf
einmal offen
juni ich weiß gar nicht mehr wo ich lang
muss ruhig man denkt an seine atmung ja
ich habe ja eine fackel dabei aber
defizit mich immer an denen meine füße
und die kag ist das denn
und die sind weg diesen weg okay das
war's dann nahm ich gehe deinen namen
auf wo bist du hier unten gingen ich
probieren blog abzubauen die ganzen
kisten hier sind hast du schon geholt
der guckt wo ich rein sie sind alle leer
komm komm ich rette dich ich hätte dich
mit auf den weg die sind ja überall die
sind ja überall hier sind jetzt zählen
wir euch welche von den türken bitte ja
ich gucke ja quasi nur an und dann
verschwinden die die haben ja angst vor
mir
o
ich habe es so angst hier sind so viele
von diesen blöd teilen
die kann er nicht gehen oder er
verschwindet er verschwindet weil er
versucht es zumindest
ich hab' ich habe gehört du bist
irgendwo in meiner nähe halbe leben
halbe leben er war ich erst weg ist weg
ich komme zu dir bist du es bei mir du
kannst doch gar keine blöcke abbauen ich
bin gefangen gerate hier ist eine kiste
mit einem handbuch oder abriss marin
titel ja ich hab diese analyse
rausgenommen da war noch mehr drin ich
bin hier gerade dann siehst du mal hab
ich bin genau neben dir ne ich sehe
einen namen nicht nee ich bin genau
rechts neben dem man die troja da stehe
ich praktisch eingebaut in der ecke
sogar noch in der einen ecke nicht
weiter ja ich kannte einer ecke nicht
weiter vor hier bin ich ich sie den
namen brechts otto usa bestimmt voll
blogger baumes müssen doch dann starb
dann vier minuten 50 diese scheiß abbau
leben ich habe 40 das können wir noch in
dieser folge eben abwarten
aber ist das packe das ist doch so kacke
hätte ich mal ne wii sowie aber was ich
da was ich nicht verstehe wieso oder in
welchen abständen kommt denn dieser
blöde pizza zu einem und sitzt einem
diesen effekt auf das wir jetzt nochmal
ich guck ich google mal leben ja du du
bist aber du bist ne ich will ja ja der
kann immer hier reinkommen ich weiß
nicht ob ich hier sicher bin ich hab
noch 114 dann könnte ich meinen weg zu
den bauern das fenster okay das ist
praktisch nur zwei drei blöcke die uns
trennen
diese meinung vertritt die weg hab dann
fertig weg habe ich direkt so geht das
halt nur noch 1 minute ich gucke immer
noch ein bisschen rum und schwimmen hier
eben dann also ich weiss nicht der gong
ist auf jeden fall da freunde so und was
wir der welt wird wird wirt unser
problem gerade ist ist dass wir ja
eigentlich nur dieses mailing für
facetime das andere dass ihr gar die
sind das ist ja schon relativ hart aber
das soll ja auch hart sein aber dieses
dieses mining kacke das trägt natürlich
schon ein wenig auf der fußball schon
jetzt ich verpasse mal diesen moment wo
ich noch einfacher setzt muss er noch 30
sekunden dann kann ich schon mal weg zu
verbauen und bisher so schnell wie mit
den og das ist echt nur zwei blöcke sich
wer bist du denn noch im wasser komplett
jeden dem wasser gerade gar nicht okay
gut es sind jetzt noch 17 sekunden ich
werd danach einfach direkt nichts du
dich zu dir durch bauen
ich habe einfach nur noch dreieinhalb
leben habe ich sogar den teilweise an
hab hab zweieinhalb kilo gold genug team
wertvoll die teuren items rosen tränke
greift man ein wächter anschütz dass ich
mit seinen stacheln die denke das war
nicht sein komme kann es denn sein
sein meine sekunden sind weggegangen
dann kam der ton blume und ich habe
wieder 59 minuten bekommt nahe
woran liegt denn das feuer griff
das kann doch nicht sein das ist doch
also wenn man den wächter nicht
eingreift schaden seine staffel nicht
aber begreift dass die stacheln sinne
der schaden die von ihm kommen
wer also sehr scheinen allen spielern in
einem radius von 50 blöcken als geist
und legen sie mit dem abbau ermüdung
effekt jede minute prüfen die großen
wächter ihre umgebung und verlängern die
ablehnung bei allen spielern die neu
sind und auch kein haben oder die eine
abbildung geringer als stufe 3 haben
oder deren abbildung 3 in weniger als
einer minute abklingen würde aber was
kann man gegen die dann machen kampf
gegen wächter wir müssen die
durchkämpfen der nahkampf gegen wächter
unter wasser ist schwer weil das wasser
die bewegung des spielers fahren gesamt
ich denke dass die damen einfach
erzielen wollen dass wir auch wirklich
durch das labyrinth durch schwimmen ja
und nein nicht irgendwie uns dadurch
bauen quasi nur dass das können wir ja
quasi gar nicht weil weil du ja diese
blöden cobblestone style gesetzt hast
oder ja aber teilweise kann man hat
daher glaube ich doch noch die chance
die kurz abzubauen am besten kann man
den gay ging wächter mit pfeil und bogen
kämpfen
gut wenn man wie jetzt ich würde sagen
ich immer die sachen hier aus der kiste
raus nützlich im kampf gegen wächter
eine starke rüstung verzauberung atmung
erhöhtem zahl unter wasser
ich freue mich dass die sachen jetzt
eben hier drin dieses buch und so ich
will mal wieder zurück dass ich auf
jeden fall schon mal an dieser base tab
in obwohl wir gerade genau wirken mcdaid
diesem weg irgendwie weil ja da da da
werde ich schon wieder irgendwie hoch
kommen würde irgendwie dass ich mal eben
kurz die folge werden kann weil sonst
muss ich die ganze wieder neue fackel
setzen hier mal eben noch zeit aber ich
kann hier auf keiner frau auf keinen
fall in der nächsten folge weiter machen
meine stelle ist er nichts ich bin ja
wir müssen dann auf jeden fall ganz kurz
überlegen wir wieder ganz machen
wir sind hier die diese karte
ich hoffe ich sterbe hier nicht noch
habe gerade ein wenig angst komme hatten
wir schon wieder ein guardian
das ist doch er kommt nicht zu nah an
die strache die können dir schaden
zufügen so ich hab noch 20 sekunden
dieser blöden lähmung bitte bitte bitte
an der zeit für mich immer wieder zurück
also den weg finde ich auf jeden fall
wieder ich bin jetzt ja auch wieder raus
gefunden hätten wir nur milch dass wir
so gut wenn wir kühler so hätten ja okay
ich bin mir da draußen
jetzt ist ein skelett fünf sekunden auf
was er jetzt gleich habe ich den er
kommt wieder näher kommt direkt bei
einer sekunde
hier unten ist auch es waren auch gerade
wieder mops hier ist auch schon wieder
guardian da hinten rum zappelt das ist
ja mal so schwer wir wissen echt nicht
wie wir weiter kommen sollen ja langsam
abbauen unser wasser mit diesem effekt
aber ich gerade gemacht hat vier minuten
um einen block abzukochen
das ist doch das kann ich nicht sein das
ist doch irgendwie ich würde sagen wir
werden erstmal die folgen dieser weise
zehn minuten angefangen
wir müssen uns jetzt wie informiert uns
jetzt mal wie wir das event weiter lösen
kann dann suchen wir eine lösung in
gómez folge und dann sehen wir uns dann
wieder rein meiner lieben ville de paris
und bis morgen